are you alive or you're saying oh my
gosh well got to listen to this guy at
four o'clock no so the question is how
do we change the world we live in I find
that as I grow older I'm more and more
conscious of the fact that it's not
sufficient to be just a consumer of
things of artifacts that other people
leave us but do we have a core play a
role to play in changing your destiny I
think there's a Chinese proverb maybe
Larry can help me of this may you live
in interest interesting times I think a
related problem might be may you live in
interesting spaces and I think Stanford
is certainly one of those spaces that I
think produces the potential to change
life outcomes I've been fortunate to
interact amazing variety of people
including dr. Dasher and I think
Stanford brings together some of the
best in the brightest who live to change
the world I'm going to take you through
this particular company which I was
fortunate to come across and I in the in
the frame of how do you shape something
I volunteered to help the company in its
evolution so today I'm going to talk
about what have we done in the space of
mass transportation I must tell you the
personal car fascinating as it may be
too many of us is actually a public
nuisance in the pursuit of personal
convenience we have created a public
menace so look at the costs of owning a
car we have certainly the internal fixed
cause of purchasing a car and we have
the internal variable costs of driving
it but we have additional external fixed
costs and this particular graph shows
you the external cause sometimes called
externalities that are imposed on this
these include parking Road facilities
lad use congestion pollution greenhouse
gases water services etc now we don't
directly pay for most of this but what
happens is we want to commute we take
our car out and before you know it we
are sitting in a giant parking lot
called 101 now how does the personal car
compared with other modes of transport
so you're here you've got the automobile
a smaller car and electric car and you
see not much changes now does it change
particularly with respect to a small
truck I'll come to the right share later
but you look at a bus electric trolley
etc all of these have costs of different
magnitudes and not particularly
different than an average automobile
except of course if you are walking or
biking in which case mostly they are
variable costs associated with your own
effort and time but you take a look at
the right share passenger which is
optimal in terms of externalities and
initial fixed costs it's mostly a
variable cost and by this we mean
essentially sharing a vehicle so that is
optimized so based on existing
technology you can see that this is true
but now let's talk about what is the
personal car do on the road it turns out
to be a phenomenal spacehog there is
something called shy distance between
one vehicle and the other and this is
the amount of space you need to maintain
so that you don't bang into the vehicle
in front and so think about it a vehicle
of about 15 feet requires like 200 feet
of distance at 60 some miles an hour to
make sure it doesn't crash into the
vehicle in front of it when it does that
it occupies a lot more of the space on a
road then let's say a bigger vehicle
which carries more passengers so this
particular artifact takes infrastructure
like an highway and converts it into
essentially far less efficient system
for transporting people and goods
the net result of this is we have
consisted our cities in an extraordinary
way if someone from outer space could
take a look at what we are doing every
day they would say these humans have
gone mad every day they rush out in the
morning at eight o'clock and then they
creep along some long passage and then
they repeat the same thing in the
evening every city and these are all the
US cities and there are two industries
here one is a travel time index which is
the amount of time over your regular if
uncongested driving time and the other
is the amount of delays / commuter now
the funny thing is advanced countries
rush into these kinds of systems whether
it is building freeway infrastructure or
metros et cetera and developing
countries creep into that or a period of
time as an aspect of development yet the
lessons that the advanced countries are
learning are often lost on the developed
countries in their pace for
industrialization many of these things
so I go to India often we are building
metro systems the first metro systems
were built in something like 1865 so
India is building metro system some 150
years later yet the problems of metro
systems are well known relatively
dedicated infrastructure servicing a
particular lane in terms of transit
extraordinarily high cause the Indian
metro system one of them is has taken 20
years and still not operational right
and of course some countries are doing
it faster but the Metro is no solution
because it doesn't solve the first and
last mile problem so you're forcing
people to come to a station to enter the
train then they'll exit somewhere else
and either have to walk or find other
transport back to their to their
workplace and then they repeat the
pattern now people say oh well let's
just increase the amount of
infrastructure then if there are so many
cars let's have more lanes more exits
but what lipman shows in a study that as
you increase interest
sure the generated traffic increases
proportionately and so you have the same
condition and in the last 10 years we
have seen this in the Bay Area we said
oh yeah bahria you know we are building
more lanes on 101 it's going to be
wonderful and we pass all these cesses
and you know additional taxes etc and
before you know it we are still on the
same parking lot so the price of not
doing it right is this everywhere in the
world developed or undeveloped countries
right so I in bangalore now the silicon
valley of india it's become the norm for
people to say don't have more than one
meeting a day right because you cannot
return from that meeting there are cases
where people fly into bangor airport and
lo behold and it's a one day trip
intending to leave the same day and they
cannot get to their meeting and they
return alright it can take three hours
sometimes so this congestion is become
so normative we expect delays we think
of it as let's plan our life to be
waiting in a parking lot creeping along
it's a very sad story so question is
what do we do we just have to think
differently now these costs huge
problems idling car sitting around
billions of dollars you have other if it
is a stationary situation then we have
this other problem of unused equipment
during non-peak hours so you see all
these buses bart trains metros they have
to run the full infrastructure even
though there's no one traveling because
they are built for peak so you got this
all this way stage got this human
wastage just imagine what would you say
is your productive day on average how
many hours how many yards is your
productive day in general so source okay
any other guesses how many out of 24
hours how many what is the human
productivity
eight hours now let's say you're working
let's say you're working in San
Francisco but living here what is their
commute time say to ours right and are
up and are now sort of an eight are
working day you just dropped your
efficiency by twenty-four twenty-five
percent right it's just incredible the
amount of human basis we talked about we
have to improve productivity we are
going to train them you're going to give
them management techniques we are going
to put them in these open space tables
everything will be magical human
productivity will increase human
productivity if it could be improved by
transit we would have solved a huge
problem so here we are introducing the
future next is a computer sorry next is
look up you just also true it was a
computer next is the company born I
needed to Italy so the founder of this
company is an Italian gentleman and
sometimes I tell people he is the blend
of Michelangelo with Elon Musk he's got
an artistic capability that is
mind-boggling at the same time in
engineering proficiency which calls to
mind the kinds of things that Tesla is
doing it's an advanced scalable mass
transit system and these are basically
made of pods which are intended to pick
up and drop off people these pods have
the ability to connect each other and
when they connect to each other they all
have the ability to open the doors in
between so that you can walk between the
pods so what happens then you can go
from one part of the other and the pods
then separate let me see if I can click
this and make something come to life
so how many of you are uber raised in
the sense that you take over as a way of
moving about maybe 10 of you I will just
pick on okay so what is uber done for us
it has said don't take out your car
instead let me have a polite gentleman
or lady come and pick you up in a very
nice vehicle and you just tell us your
destination and we'll drop you off it's
amazing invention or innovation using
existing technologies right apart from
the orchestration of demand and supply
what we are doing if you will is the
next stage where we are talking about
mass customized transit so now let's
just take the open problem which is
person a wants to go from you know X to
Y but if you have persons ABCD wanting
to go to destinations XYZ how do you
accommodate that problem right now in an
over situation it may be multiple cars
and of course uber has come up with
rideshare etc but doesn't always get us
that optimality so we talked about
multiple types of optimality one is the
optimality associated with human time
utilization we talked about optimality
associated with freeway infrastructure
we talked about optimality of running
you know the right kinds of costs
because costs finally get back to us
whether it's metros or cars on the
freeway or additional roads so when
you're talking about different kinds of
optimality how do you solve for
optimality in mass transit so that's the
problem we are trying to solve so as you
can see in this pod let's say you got
onto this pod and these let's say this
is four or six pods long you are based
on your destination that you have dialed
up in your app it says move to pod
number three that is going to saratoga
part number two
who's the neighbor that you SAT with who
was picked up in the same vehicle might
be going to San Jose so he's invited to
go to part number one because that is
going to san jose now all of you are
picked up at home and you're going to be
individually dropped off in your place
of work and the pattern repeats itself
all right so how does it contrasts with
let's say a bus it will be cheaper than
a bus because we will be let's so how
would we look at a business model then
I'll come to prices and costs so
initially we are thinking that we will
replace existing fleets which are
servicing local neighborhoods campuses
etc like the Marguerite let me see
there's an animation which plays here
say media not found okay all right any
uh no worries so anyhow so what one can
what this is illustrating is initially
what we would do is to have these
modules replace these fleets and we
would start assembly of these modules so
what we are creating is a scalable bus
right we are saying the simplest version
is one module which is like you know ten
feet long you know normal width so it
can operates on existing roads in your
neighborhood then it starts assembling
itself into a bus so it can be four
modules long it can be ten modules long
and each one of these modules
essentially consists of four wheels
electric each individual independently
steered and then it starts connecting
itself now the last slide here the last
part of slide here is showcasing
something that we call on demand
services and we re conceptualizing what
it means to actually be in transit so as
Tommaso indicated in his slide our
founder the concept is life in motion so
the question is what do you do when you
are in transit now what we do normally
is to grip the steering wheel and listen
to the radio and curse the guy in front
of us right but what is you could be
relaxed you could be entertained you
could call for a starbucks module to
come and attached to you so that you can
have your cappuccino you could have a
business meeting by having Regis model
connect to you and you have an office
that is in the next module what if a
cinema can attach to you AMC has a
module which comes and shows you the
latest movie right what if we could have
a battery module which comes and
replaces batteries so that you never and
don't have to stop and you can go from
coast to coast so we are imagining these
modules which are specialized modules
which can do a variety of functions so
in that sense we say transit need not be
a waste of time transit is something
that you do while you are doing
something more
now in terms of comparison of course we
are seeing certainly in a valley the
self-driving car there are these modular
pods which are single person vehicles
and then there's a self-driving bus we
are already seeing through auto and
other initiatives the notion of a
self-driving truck and self driving
buses are coming but the key thing is
how much occupancy can you get a model
modular part you can get hundred percent
because it's one person occupying one
seat self-driving cars maybe there are a
couple of people self driving buses
because of peak and non-peak issues is
inevitably slower we believe we can get
a much higher occupancy rate our traffic
footprint is obviously fairly small
compared to you know most entities and
our total cost per passenger kilometre
and we have estimated at point zero
eight there is some factoring of the
fact that electric batteries will get
cheaper and it's easier to charge
etcetera etcetera but fundamentally and
the part that we have can see today's
six passengers maybe ten standing and if
you pay a fit like a normal bus about 50
passengers we occupy about 53 feet with
eight modules and versus 10 cars will
now have a distance of about 60 meters
so that's the difference between us and
a solution which is dynamically
assembled to carry multiple passengers
versus a rigid system or an inefficient
one previous slide the modular pod
you're talking about there would be an
individual in one pot not one person per
pod what's the difference between next
and the modular pods Mario part is
actually single person almost like a
airline seat moving a writer okay
whereas ours currently is designed for
six passenger seat okay and I'll show
you a picture of our full-scale one
so what happens during a rush are right
we are traffic efficient as a bus as
efficient as a bus fully loaded bus and
therefore we have a hundred percent load
factor and we are occupying minimal
space etc and therefore next guarantees
to eighty percent less traffic
congestion and thirty-one percent lower
fuel consumption so at peak traffic we
are actually very efficient now what
happens at medium traffic issues we are
ubiquitous and fuel efficient as a
shared taxi during low and medium
traffic so next guarantees greater
occupancy more frequency and lower fuel
consumption in that phase as well
because we are optimizing that the
number of modules that connect and the
number of people promote you and then
you look at low traffic we are probably
the best because much like a solution of
individual needs as required we operate
the modules in fact we while we are
still in our development stages we are
quite surprised we got a mail one day
from a mayor of a town in Germany he
said I would like to order your pods
right now now we have not yet built a
working full-scale model but he wants 50
of these pods why he says I'm a small
town I'm operating some 50 buses and I
and the reason I have all these buses
and the drivers is because I need to
have service during festivals that I
operate and if I don't have that then I
cannot meet the requirement of visitors
coming into my town yet during all the
times that there is no festival I'm just
idling the buses and I'm idling the
workers right and they have to be
maintained etc etc I would love to have
your ports right so he said you look at
weight muscle much like what Elon Musk
is telling us got to wait so we did a
simulation of what it might be from here
to San Francisco let's say you know
going to Mountain View you this your
next appt
and you decide tell us tell it where to
go and it picks you up and it picks up
others and now it starts assembling
itself on route and there will be driven
of these going along the route as it
forms the bus train as we call it and
then gradually it frees up other modules
you know some might head off it on the
bottom bridge some might head off to on
92 if the regulator's allowed allow it
we might go on the HOV Lane but any case
we eventually end up in the city and
then distribute the pods to the location
that you want I remember as a young kid
I had been used to traveling on trains
which did not have the ability to go
from one coast to the other I don't know
I wonder how many people in this room
have experienced that anyone where the
coaches don't allow you to transit so
you got into one coach at the trail way
station but you cannot get to the next
one until the train stops at a station
anyone experienced that yeah well it was
very common in India until we suddenly
got these coaches that had the
vestibular connection and suddenly it
was magical right you could what the
length of the train and you could go to
the restaurant car and so on right and
since we have time I remember that in
that journey the way in which you got
meals was everything used to be loaded
on to one coach and the people used to
transfer their meal trays from the
outside while the train was in motion
almost like acrobats because there was
no way to get to the coach and serve the
meal any case what we are doing is
something similar we are saying what if
we could give you the ability to go from
one coach to the other while in transit
now the business scenario of this is we
initially intend to sell into the public
transportation is agencies and the
operators that serve that scenario and
users would then consume that app
identify their solution set and off they
go but there are other variations right
which is which is the scenario but there
are other possibilities so what if we
said there's a consumer version of this
and you don't need to buy your car but
you buy a next module and you park it in
your driveway and when you want to use
it you climb on it and move on and if
not you allow it to be summoned and it
goes and services other people so this
is the social pooling sharing scenario
and I think Tesla also has something
like that in mind potentially with this
or a new feature that he released
yesterday then you've got this augmented
used scenario that I talked about which
is specialization which allows you to
convert which allows businesses to say
that earlier and and I want to contrast
this with e-commerce so what did
ecommerce change so before we had a
system where you would go to a store you
would go to walmart target etc by things
then amazon came and said amongst others
you don't need to do that you just go to
the web you order and the object comes
to you so now play that's same scenario
out for other services today we go to a
hotel and check in we go to a Starbucks
and drink their coffee and we go to a
Regis office space and rent their
conference room but what if all of that
could come to you so that's the scenario
we are talking about here whether these
businesses would reinvent themselves by
saying we are Hilton we have 5000 hotels
on the move these hotels can come to you
right and the starbucks modules can come
and attached to you and deliver
beverages when you want and so on so our
first market strategy is to replace
public transportation inefficient fleet
now there's a logical construct to this
all fleets need replacement upgrades
whatever and so we want to be in the in
the throes of that and here's an example
for for example Singapore so 4,000 some
buses is a fleet size of Singapore and
let's say we take eight modules to
replace one bus so now you have got the
potential to have an NVA we are
anticipating a conversion fleet
conversion rate of you know 10 to 60
percent depending on that you can see
that we have a substantial line of
business that we could do just in
Singapore with fairly substantive
margins now this is not to minimize the
effort involved in bringing something
like this to market so our first we are
not a vehicle manufacturer although we
have built multiple prototypes small and
big including full scale so initially we
would go to manufacturers who are
professionals at building prototypes and
we have quotations from many of these
and they are eager to build us one or
many but these are people who
essentially manufacture the first units
so these units can cost up to a million
bucks the first unit right are expected
price and as it drops rapidly and you
can see the simplicity of our design we
basically are a shell with a chassis
four wheels independently driven
electric motors attached and software so
the amount of effort involved in
building one of these is not significant
and we expect and of course a bunch of
sensors all around the vehicle we expect
the price of this to drop fairly rapidly
under volume and eventually we feel that
these can be
assembled as a kit so hopefully we can
drop it into Africa and people assemble
it in a few hours and they have a next
module that is connected to the global
positioning system and is often running
so in that sense we expect prices to
drop fairly rapidly and we anticipate
that this could be in the range of you
know under a hundred thousand dollars in
a relatively short period of time now I
stalking Larry earlier as we were
waiting for the car this meeting to
start the question is where do these
kinds of solutions fit would they fit in
a developed country like the u.s.
Germany France etcetera where there's an
extensive fairly large economy fairly
extensive public transport system
therefore the ability to offer tall
those all of these things and the answer
is yeah the money is there the market
may be there but the inclination to
allow solutions like this is relatively
low so we are participating in Smart
City initiatives in the US and other
places and we find while there is
interest the momentum to actually get to
working Road solution is not as high now
cars autonomous cars are coming in
suddenly and and we will use that will
platoon in to that effect and hopefully
be advantaged but there is going to be
time before all of that happens the
second set of possibilities are cities
that are being constructed in india and
china etc where a ton of money is going
into new infrastructure would that be
the place to go and find our market on
the reality of those city of those
cities and countries is while you might
not be challenged with existing
infrastructure you are challenged with
ways of doing business and the fact that
you're trying to introduce something new
and novel in a place that might not
necessarily allow it the third
possibility the things that we attire
trying with right now or places where
there is money the inclination and the
appetite to digest innovation one such
place turns out to be due by this is His
Majesty the ruler of Dubai Sheikh
Mohammed Al Maktoum and he has got a
vision by 2030 he wants twenty-five
percent of all traffic in Dubai to be
autonomous now he has just picked it up
enough from somewhere and he says this
is a vision I the ruler have ok so now
he has instructed his ministries and
he's got visions in various things
amount of co2 to be emitted in the
atmosphere etc etc and when he tweeted
this he used our picture we didn't we
have no presence and we had no presence
into why at that time but it is
illustrative of the fact that there are
people who have impact who see this as a
viable solution through eight ministries
he's now said I want you guys the heads
of these ministries to impact how this
vision is going to be achieved based on
that they started something called the
Dubai Future Foundation which is vested
out of billion dollars of some money the
Dubai future foundation then launched
something called the Dubai future
accelerators this they invited companies
from around the world to bid for a slot
in their accelerator program we were
lucky to be chosen we were one of 30
some companies chosen out of 2,000 and
so companies and we were in the road and
transport agency segment so there are
three companies in that segment one is
Hyperloop the second is ours and the
third one is a compliment so we are
working actively we are present in Dubai
RT my team is in dubai right now and we
are working with the agency there to
figure out how to bring the solution to
life and i must tell you that it has
been exhilarating experience the people
are motivated they want to get this
solution out
dubois hosting expo 2020 as and this
these expose happen once every five
years and what we have proposed is that
vb one of the solution providers 4x4
2020 to illustrate that you can order a
mobile unit to come and pick you up and
that mass transit of this time can be
happy can happen so that happened and
this was a doo doo doo doo doo forget
what they don't let's say couple months
had three months back or so this is much
more recent so this is third of october
we are now into by that's a manual a or
my colleague and CEO of the company this
is His Highness Sheikh Maktoum and here
we are demonstrating two units coupled
in motion so we have written the
software for these units 2 couple and D
Kapoor and we showed a small track they
actually come by I forgot to bring the
video associated with that but if any of
you are interested we can study send
send you that but so now we have written
demonstrated the ability for something
like this to occur that independence can
sense each other when there is proximity
then goes and aligns itself in a track
it senses the roadway through cameras
and then it in our couples and decouples
we also put together a full-scale
prototype and we built two prototypes
and we exhibited this at a no trans in
Bullen and then because Dubai insisted
on having these prototypes we had signed
up a relationship a strategic
relationship with cream at the name yeah
cream is the uber of the Middle East
fairly significant player and what we
have done is to say let us bring the
solution forward together so dubois
karim says to launch driverless pot test
within a year so this was in the Khaleej
Times a couple days back so we are all
over the news in
dubai in terms of bringing this to life
as a relatively viable proposition we
are actually we I tell my colleagues we
have too much press we are very very
visible very public you know we are
written up about all the time and
personally I'd rather have less
publicity at this age of of our
evolution it's like praising a kid that
he is going to be Einstein before the
kid has gone to school so but that's
where we are I guess we should consider
ourselves fortunate but we are fairly
visible that's my story and I'm sticking
to it there are all kinds of directions
to go for questions on this what's the
hardest technology part to this and
you're saying the hardest technology
part because they're their various
things there yeah autonomous vehicle I
there's the routing technology that
software right the hardest technology
piece of this is going to be for us when
we are putting these pods together now
you got a multiplicity each part has got
four independently steerable wheels as
you put these together we are still
operating every modules wheels right so
the module is still in transit so now
imagine that I have to come around a
curve or I have to overtake another car
etc the complexity of steering every
wheel at speed optimally is a
non-trivial problem right now trains do
this easily because they are going on a
track cars and buses do it because they
have rigid where the axles and you know
if the steering is on one one axle or
the other here we are doing simultaneous
steering so with that complexity comes
opportunity this is
can can can literally spin on its wheels
right but we all we have to do is change
the turning radius of each one of these
units non-trivial complexity we solved a
piece of it we are showing it at slow
speed for two modules but I can imagine
when it is four modules and eight
modules it's a non-trivial problem what
kind of a timetable do you have are you
going to be in Dubai for this 2020 Expo
so the accident program ends mid
December but what we are talking
discussing with the road and transport
authority is a phased approach to
delivering real solutions by 2020 and we
will see whether it happens I mean as to
us it was serendipitous that we got
chosen and but we have to see whether
the evolution remain stable as predicted
as predicted there is enormous interest
we are certainly there it is like an
Arabian Nights story we are situated
along with all these other companies in
the emirates towers which is where the
Prime Minister's offices and this
gentleman you know I didn't know much
about him earlier quite remarkable he
just walks about and it's not unknown
for him to be in the coffee shop at
starbucks in that in that entity which
also hosts a very public mall to be
having coffee and paying for it so he is
that kind of a guy so apparently that
vision then prevails that other people
are motivated to act in the best
interest of Dubai so we will see I mean
no it's the to us also it's an
experiment but so far we are very
impressed by how its big run so one of
the things that interested me about this
from the very beginning a few years ago
I heard Scott McNealy the former CEO of
Sun Microsystems say that uber is
interesting autonomous cars are
interesting autonomous uber is a lot
more interesting and then just recently
there is a kind of shared version of
uber called chariot that started up in
the bay area where people really are
sharing rides and cutting the cost down
by doing this and this is one generation
beyond
that it combines both of those um but
there's an awful lot of kind of
uncertainty with regard to human
behavior the human behavior outside this
vehicle right yeah outside the vehicle
and also what people will pay for right
so if you factor in time efficiency and
what they and this is what I understand
for instance from my google friends they
might be top executives they might have
a test Laura Tesla in their driveway
many of them actually take the Google
bus because it changes what you can do
with your time No so in that sense I I
believe that there is there's going to
be a lot of pickup even same reason that
chariot is now getting more popular and
the fact that at a minimum you get an
advantage of personal use of time we
apart from early adoption issues of you
know is the safe is it going to do what
I'm what I think it might do I think we
will adopt it if it is available I
remember the resistance to Oberon ish
alee and and similar things like hola in
India I don't know this driver is he
certified you know where will it be safe
true and there are some photos to be
crossed and you know certain kinds of
new kinds of systems cameras alarming
systems etcetera to be put in place but
once you do now most people get up a
plane and as a plane you know as they
reach the baggage area they say it get
me over the Hooper is there and off they
go and you think look at other people
waiting in taxi line and seeing it did
they get the memo from the office saying
use uber so things change yeah well
that's very true how much can you tell
us about the state of the company in
terms of funding and
terms a number of employees right now
what kind of a you know projection do
you have about how much it's going to
cost to really get this off the ground
so we are very early stage we are about
15 people total we are self-funded at
the present time you're looking for
money so when you look for money as well
many of you know you look for the right
kind of money it's not just the money
that you need right now but the money
leads to other money that can eventually
stage you know things like new kinds of
customers and interesting exits etc so
we are in that early we have not yet
done a series a so we are looking for
money right now at the same time what
you do with these kinds of things is you
never take money too early and you don't
take too much money at the wrong time
you don't give up too much control at
the same time you want certain kinds of
strategic relationships so just as a as
Richard mentioned earlier I had it in a
book long time back and in that book I
talked about there are three C's that
you have to watch when you are running a
company all right first C is controls
when you I'm sorry the first sees
choices what choice do you make so for
instance as next let us say we were
approached by GM and we were approached
by Mercedes right and they say we would
we love your technology we would love to
be part of what you're doing blah blah
blah let me give you some money right
let me give you a million bucks should
we take that money let's say we are
starving we don't have money I have an
offer to offers one from Mercedes one
from GM what should I do thoughts five
let's say they fight let's say my name
or your company yeah let's say they
fight and they said GM says I need two
million Mercedes is giving only one I
leave it to what should i do then you
make a term which is favorable to you
okay how do I decide that depends on the
situation depends what you have in your
hand you paint want the customer warn
you have to identify it so let us say I
take bill all that is beautiful okay so
I love the story gM says you know what
I'm going to make you very happy you
know you're all GM employees you know
I'm going to acquire you for ten million
i'm gonna peel the product for you so
that you can help money yeah but who can
have money GM yeah so this is what
happens right there when you play these
large companies you cannot control your
revolution so what happens is many
companies there's a Richard K tell you
they canceled the project now what are
you going to do you are your last year's
interesting baby to this year you are
not interesting anymore and suddenly
you're stuck so the first see is choices
how do you make choices for a company
the second see is controls so given a
choice the controls that you have
suddenly change right so the VC looks at
you and says oh you took funding from GM
that's very interesting because you have
just written off every other bus
manufacturer in the world they say oh I
did that I just wanted money no you made
a choice and with that choice you gave a
control it's not necessarily a bad
choice but your destiny just changed so
choices controls and then you have to
live with the consequences your path is
now defined by the control that you
exercise from the choices that you made
any of that's the dimensionality of
funding that we are looking at for
instance here for instance we are wind
ooh boy we have interest from players
there who have a lot of money we are
having many interesting conversations
but we will come upon a time and we say
we make this choice or not and we
allowed to see I'll come to you for
advice so one of the things that I
noticed about what you said is that
really you've been looking so you get
you get contacted by the mayor of the
Germantown and you're in Dubai doing
these experiments in dubai now you're
aware of the situation in India very
well what would you like to see in terms
of global expansion what kind of a
pattern do you think would make the most
sense and that's not necessarily what
the company is going to do okay I'm
going to remove that so that you're not
speaking for the company I think as
humans we are not solving macroeconomic
issues this is showing up in many
different dimensions you look at
pollution we are literally ruining our
planet because we say I have a right to
pollute right and there's no consequence
to that in India as many of you some of
you might have gone it is dirty like you
know crazy no it's a really filthy why
because we take no responsibility it's
okay just toss the crash right similarly
in our what we think is advanced
technology behavior we take bhai what
the latest BMW you know it's got this
and that the reality is it's one person
driving a hundred thousand dollar
machine which is ekström extraordinarily
inefficient in terms of a macro economic
behavior right but we sustain that
behavior and we do not engage with each
other on how to find optimality and
finally the consequence is this network
effect works out where everyone is
solving for personal optimality and ends
up that no one is optimal because we are
all sitting in this macro parking lot
what I would like to see is things that
rather than being pure ative that like
London is imposed on if you enter London
between this time and that time you have
surcharges which are very high now
instead of that what you have is a
system it says why would you want to
drive your car into London downtown we
have a better system
and that comes from saying we have these
kinds of solutions they got ways to get
you there you know where it's uber ride
share or other ways which give people
options of commuting in with delight and
convenience so that they are not seeking
that personal optimal solutions so the
Singapore is a case in point I think
they have solved relatively well
compared to many other large cities it
is safe great mass transit you know you
can get around town very easily but if
you try to bring a car into Singapore
your penalties like 5x or some huge
number in a small car in Singapore like
a Toyota Camry might cost you well
100,000 bucks and it is not easy to get
their license to import now that is a
punitive way of doing it I don't think
they should be there but that must hear
if we are intelligent human beings that
has got to be a more optimal way of
doing this yeah it is interesting that
Singapore is where the one of the first
autonomous uber type companies is
located right in the autonomy so that's
already under trial I think so and they
have money they have a need right you
have choices yeah we hope we hope to
hear from the mayor of Singapore let's
open the floor any questions or comments
from the audience go ahead my questions
regards safety in the United States if
you're in a bus like a greyhound bus you
don't have air bags you don't need
seatbelts but if a car hits of us you're
not going to get hurt you're in a car or
van or something you have airbags
seatbelts and proposals what is your
company's position on providing the same
safety if you're not on your toddler's
car can be smart not thought anything
else but if somebody it's you you have
no control as it is simple it's not
rocket science as a regulatory
requirement is to solve for seat belts
and sort for us all four airbags we will
if you are operating their environment
that is not a technology hurdle it's
only a pricing issue and if the market
will bear the price so be it so I could
see several variations one of the things
in the
video is your your applicant the app on
your smartphone tells you that you need
to move to another module it may be that
that could only happen while the the
Train is stopped could be right that
would pull over to the side and let
people switch modules at some point yeah
but you know in most countries I don't
know that I think in the u.s. they say
please do not stand up and move in the
bus while it's in motion right I don't
know whether it's a regular it's a
operator discretion or it is a regulator
regulatory requirement post buses don't
have air bags and do not have seatbelts
so that is the operational mechanism
here if you go to India or many other
places or people will be walking up and
down doing all kinds of things so the
regulatory environment is different and
the speeds are of course much slower
right so I believe we can meet those
kinds of requirements easily are the
center of gravity of our vehicle is
extremely low the battery is at below
the chassis and if you couple the weight
of the chassis and the weight of the
batteries this vehicle is not easy to
overturn right so yes there can be
damaged due to a head-on collisions at
all that but this is true of any
operating vehicle I would have to follow
up on your point and say that this is a
great example of kind of our version of
innovation where you develop a new
technology and you figure that the
regulatory situation will catch up with
it eventually uber is a great example of
that no one knew how that should be
regulated is it really a public
transportation company or is it a
sharing company no one knew what to do
with that the liability issues had not
been worked out and a lot of places in
Asia have been very hesitant to make any
kind of technology innovation until the
government regulation specifically says
you can do this or we would like to
support ideas in this space so that
you're actually running ahead of that
and I do think that's kind of a an
approach that we have on this side of
the Pacific more than in most
economy but we are seeing an
intermittent in intermediate state where
for limited environments so let us say
people Foxconn runs big factories people
have to move from their accommodation to
the factory one could argue that that
kind of transit system can be easily
regulated it's an internal environment
you put a dedicated lane you put sensors
and you say okay this is the way in
which traffic moves up and down right so
I I believe that there are systems in
our places where we can innovate like
that to get people comfortable and
refine the technology okay other
questions or comments how many of you
would want to ride in something like
this yeah you find it interesting enough
yeah where should we what would love to
hear your thoughts you're all smart
people Stanford Bay Area Silicon Valley
global what should we do advise me back
and back go ahead you can also here we
go excellent right then again it's a
little bit like before it's right it
comes and picks you up where you want to
be picked up so that case like you know
in berwyn demands increases just like
surgery right are you also going to a
surgery so the other operators right you
have technology providers so the
operator will decide these kinds of
things we hope that will be a customer
of this and they can decide i have
decided in the united states one of the
very first places where i really see a
business in this between Los Angeles and
Las Vegas yeah that's a family that
would you know you pick people off from
all over Los but Los Angeles and the bus
the symbols and there's booze in the bus
now I focus my talk mostly on people
movement but the more likely evolution
is actually cargo movement and we are
going to see a lot of that happening so
think of it once again viewed from space
we are
a mega organism consuming food every day
and dispersing garbage right food has to
come in every day and has to not be
taken out as junk that process today is
done by truckers there are about 1.5
million truckers in the u.s. moving
stuff through the various you know from
factories to distribution points to
retail stores etc that system is going
to change due to autonomous driving
there are already autonomous trucks in
the system and be plan to impact that as
well so imagine for a minute I'll just
take Dubai is an example to buy gross
practically nothing right everything is
flown in so we could have a system which
says go to the cargo plane suck out
fresh lettuce strawberries what have you
that needs to supply the city attach
yourself to the local grocery store
distribute the you know good evening
some other system of this picks up the
garbage and puts it in the in the city
dump you see that as a viable path for
us
what do you guys think
GV go people are illegal cargo choices
because a common I don't know which
government official nor agency made this
comment but it was the Highway Safety
Department something to that effect and
they were citing the traffic deaths i
think in 2015 and we'll caught me most
was the statement made that they
expected there to be zero traffic
fatalities in the next dipping 20 to 30
years which to me was code for
autonomous vehicles otherwise what
justification would they possibly have
to make that's where comment that's not
in fact the more dangerous entity on the
road is the human driver right drunk
inattentive what have you I've been
available to the truck I think musta
been a trucking firm that was trying to
justify the use of autonomous trucks
based upon a thing for the difficulty in
procuring labor justify but the same
time as I said there are 1.5 million
drivers we're going to be put out of
work because of technologies like this
and and I we we are entering a world of
disruption and we are going to redefine
you know what does it mean to have a job
contracting associate so is 3.5 oh there
you go okay and what it's all about the
afraid immediately I can see somebody
like FedEx because they have a
combination of very large vehicles and
also they have to have very much smaller
vehicles to deliver in the neighborhood
that's right if you had a robotic kind
of system inside the vehicle to move the
packages around we have done that we
have done a design of this which is the
UPS FedEx version of it which is it's
loaded in the UPS center then as it
comes towards your home it moves a
parcel to the right window which opens
only for you when you punch a security
code which actually suggests that some
place like Japan might really be an
early adopter okay there's so much
overnight delivery in Japan I think and
even the convenience stores in Japan
typically have between five and seven
deliveries a day Wow because they have
no place to store inventory of the
local store so this kind of you know
there's a lot of opportunities that are
a little bit different than different
locations the other thing I should
mention is people ask and one of the
early models that I suggested was that
there are rotating shuttles which pick
up people and drop them at a staging
place and then it starts assembling
itself into bigger units which then
transit let's say the I've a segment and
then it splits up into other modular
pieces so and the phase one of this I
suggested was human-driven that these
are all caught drivers are now at the
head of these modules right so in an
earlier lecture someone asked me well
what will those other drivers do once
this gets assembled and you need only
one driver for six modules what happened
to the other five drivers two answers to
such questions one is the world is
changing and no one has a permanent job
the second answer is maybe the passenger
is the driver so out of that set of six
times you know seven modules 42 people
being driven you have six people who are
driving modules and they get compensated
for driving these modules so essentially
you are picking up a few people and then
attaching yourself and off you go make
sense suppose you had one dollar to
contribute to this company how many of
you would contribute one dollar because
you think it's a viable concept I'm not
asking you to contribute anything I'm
just asking curious whether it's you see
the city festival at this point maybe
hundred percent so other questions go
ahead oh okay oh go ahead this one I
mentioned it is a company called parts
enterprises you're probably familiar
with that which one is basically a
storage place as a matter of fact I
sorry i was just look
no because I wanted to rent one and
basically they bring the part of your
home and they use it to storage or to
move I said I have a service coming
deliver just like a fedex okay and it's
a wonderful service and matter i was
talking to my daughter last week about
renting she sold her holes so that's
something you might want to look into it
then when you say part what exactly
doesn't mean we mean one of these
abbreviation no no thought it'd be mean
a border fact that this one I have not
thought of that you know TLA for the
party I don't know what this stands for
but I think it is portable on demand
beautiful very nice go ahead but if you
can sell to walmart and the every city's
local garbage system I mean in your data
versus to walmart and then you collect
the garbage and here in time you don't
bump into anybody else may be easier to
implement you know the eponymous world
is coming upon us faster than we think i
was in el camino hospital the other day
and this little robot this knows how to
dial the elevator button go to the right
floor and deliver medicine another time
I went to the stanford mall have you
seen that robotic policeman this
policeman is this big it's huh oh no not
nothing seriously okay that's a problem
but I do I have heard that Stanford is
planning on a test of making the
marguerite autonomous but they're
they're planning on putting on a couple
of autonomous vehicles in the middle of
the bus fleet and that's all I know but
I have heard this I'd be good to talk to
them yeah okay so if there's no further
questions we've got some refreshments
outside I do want to say that this is
thanks to the allen minor foundation
that we have some refreshments please
stay and let's talk more informally
about this idea sweeter thanks so much
thank you great tonic
you